president joe biden he had a welcome to
tampa bay bucks
all right so this is the first time
brady went to the white house since i
think 2006.
he hasn't made the trips do you guys
like this new version of tom brady i am
going to play you guys this clip from
brady today
okay and he was good um let me get my
um
i'm gonna play this guys for you right
now we're here today uh to congratulate
and welcome uh to the white house the
super bowl champion
tampa bay buccaneers uh it was actually
very challenging seasons for a lot of
reasons we worked really hard
we put all our individual agendas aside
and we came together as a team
if you look at us we're all a little bit
different ages i'm a little older than
most of them
but we come from a lot of different
places across the country a lot of
different schools a lot of different
backgrounds but
uh we love each other we're committed to
one another we found our rhythm
we got on a roll not a lot of people uh
you know think that we could have won
and um in fact i think about 40 percent
of the people still don't think we won
i understand do you understand that mr
president i understand that
yeah and personally you know it's nice
for me to be back here
we had a game in chicago where i forgot
what down it was
i lost track of one down and 21 years of
playing
and they started calling me sleepy tom
why would they do that to me
[Applause]
not bad i mean he's got a joke writer i
mean he looks amazing
did you find that funny did you find i
mean he knew how to play for the crowd i
guess uh
yeah it took biden to secondary to get
it yeah i wonder if the kids in syria
thought that was funny i don't know
what you think jeff don't do you like
this version of brady who is a
completely different person than he was
for the first 18 years of his career
i have to admit i do i do i mean i also
like the uh the roasts on comedy central
yeah one of the favorite things and
that's what it was he was basically a
roast
got a great tick tock yeah yeah wait
time out who's roast
no no tom basically is uh is roasting
with the one-liners here
at the
it's unbelievable though i mean how
belichick keeps these guys under his
thumb
because you would never see even an
inkling of that from brady
during his patriots career and and i
like this version of him i think he's
i think if he had done it the opposite i
don't think he could have done it i
don't think he could have played for
tampa bay for 16 17 years
and then close it out under belichick
yeah it'd be very difficult but now
i think he you know what i don't see the
end to this i
i'm not looking at this is his last year
i don't think they're going to win the
super bowl again they caught lightning
in a bottle last by the way he played
with a knee injury the entire season
unbelievable but it's refreshing he's
very active on social media he's more
likeable now
totally than he was he was a little bit
robotic back with the patriots and he's
a completely different person
well i i mean look why wouldn't you be
like this is everything at this point's
a legacy play for him
now you as a manager what i'd love to
know because i used to make this point
i'm friends with a few giants i used to
make this point and them all the time i
was like how much money does eli manning
need
at this point this dude should be taking
less money he's getting 100 million from
toyota and
and movado anyway you know dunkin donuts
is paying
his his mortgage take less money and get
yourself a couple offensive linemen
get yourself a couple of wide receivers
everything's a legacy play at this point
i don't know how the nfl pa
lets brady do these 12 million dollar a
year
deals well it was never that i was just
going to say that's why because the pa
in every sport right
kind of makes sure that whoa whoa whoa
don't yeah reset the market here
exactly so there's a little bit of that
going on but um
tom brady did it but it's not like he
took peanuts right it's like
tom brady comparatively right but why
did
he wasn't in the top 10. no it could
have been 25 million then he was making
22 million
but the top 10 i mean the difference was
only a few million dollars look what
happened with russell
wilson look what happened with ben
roethlisberger look what happened with
even aaron rodgers what
when these guys got their mega deal the
team around them
kind of dissipated right when they're
when you're counting one player is 30
of your salary cap i mean that's really
you talk about the brilliance of tom
brady tom brady went to a new place
didn't max out his contract and said
build a team around me he understands
legacy
and he understands branding in ways
lebron never well it's funny because you
know he's friends with trump
he he can't admit it anymore but that
had to be kind of bizarre for him you
know performing for joe biden today
pretty strange
i hope you enjoyed that short clip from
episode 2 of sports now with tom zenner
there's more where that came from here's
another short clip for you to click on
from episode 2
or episode 2 in its entirety right here
and don't forget to subscribe to
valuetainment sports